on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored with
me Jeremy Kyle trust in trust collapses
with our economy in meltdown tonight a
bombshell poll gives labor a staggering
33-point lead the question is it time
for an emergency u-turn on Britain's tax
cut Gamble
Computing Alex's four parts of Ukraine
and prepares to send thousands of Aging
conscripts to war could threatening
Russia with attack bring an end to the
fighting we'll debate that later
and a major new survey says the Brits
are basically fat layer belts but are we
really lazier than anybody else
[Music]
good evening my friends and a big big
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored yes
he's still up north playing golf not
very well I'm Jeremy Kyle and of course
hurricane Ian made landfall in the U.S
today here in Britain it's a case of
hurricane Eaton an out of touch Ravel
tearing through the British economy
leaving Millions without power and
threatened to drown us all in debt it's
been a week believe it or not since the
government's fiscal experiment I said
that quite well and the results are
quite remarkable Rising debt mortgages
exploding pensions collapsing we've got
interest rates higher than a hippie in a
hot air balloon and the only thing
tanking harder than the pound is you've
got it Liz truss's reputation trust in
trust they said well she certainly put
the rust in trust this is all written by
the wonderful Alex the gag in mortgage
the broken broker and the chancellor en
Chancellor above all the pm has pulled
off something that seemed almost
impossible she's made so dreary Starman
look competent and interesting believe
it or not a poll tonight gives labor a
staggering 33-point lead their biggest
since the 1990s now we were very
critical of the Prime Minister for
hibernating during this economic
meltdown there were no statements there
were no interviews and today my friends
we found out why because every time she
opened a Gob the markets recoil quite
simply ready for this she has the minus
touch everything she touches turns to
mold her interviews with eight friendly
local radio stations this morning were
supposed to spread calm throughout our
nation but the only people who benefited
with the RAC because frankly we had a
series of repetitive slow-motion car
crashes across the length and breadth of
his country pin back your logos and have
a listen to this shambles
where have you been
well I think we've got to remember the
situation we were facing this winter we
were facing a situation where people
could have had to pay energy bills of up
to six thousand pounds I think we have
to remember what situation this country
was facing you know we were going into
the winter with people
expected to face fuel bills of up to six
thousand pounds people were facing fuel
bills of up to six thousand pounds
every BBC local radio station this
morning
big moment there for the bloke from
Brazil uh it I gather from that that
every person thought there was going to
be a bill of six thousand pounds now
we're joined Jesus Jenners are back talk
TV Legend Mike Graham political Journeys
Ava Santina and journalists and
Economist Paul Mason
um good Lord um I I found myself Mikey
last night sitting here thinking I've
become a socialist overnight I do not
understand so is everybody else well I
don't understand here's the thing right
um
who did not say to this woman that if
you if you release a policy that frankly
says okay I'll bring in tax cuts but
it's going to affect the poor and not
the rich how did anybody in her cabinet
her government or anybody having any
sense of what she felt was right or
wrong could think that was a good thing
don't get it well I think she's probably
the worst Communicator I've ever seen
and he's still Ronald Reagan the great
communicator she's whatever the opposite
of that is she can't seem to get a
message across I don't think the budget
was a terrible mistake I I'm not one of
those that thinks you should reverse it
and if you give people tax money back
obviously if you pay more tax you get
more back then if you don't pay so much
tax so I don't think that's the problem
but I think the banks have been
absolutely out of control the money
market has been out of control the the
currency dealers have been out of
control and I just don't think they know
what they're doing and they're hoping
against hope that it all just goes away
I don't know what they're going to do
next week it's interesting isn't it Paul
welcome to the show first time I know um
sunak has as reportedly said tonight I
won't be at the Tory Party Conference
I'm going to get Liz to own this um he
repeatedly said I'm going to raise
tagbody thought that you know this guy
was you know he'd back hour isn't he he
actually predicted the pawn would fall
and the bond market would go into free
fall and it's not only him it's it's
it's 101 in the treasury rule book if
you're going to borrow money and give it
away to rich people okay there has to be
some quid pro quo there has to be
something that offsets that is it is it
public spending cut so we're going to
see hospitals close they won't tell us
um so there's nothing there's nothing to
explain either to the ordinary person or
more importantly the people lending the
money to the government
how it's going to work and if you can't
show your workings to these guys sitting
there with these two big Bloomberg
terminals in the city of London they're
not going to believe you and so I I
think you know I disagree with you Mike
I I don't agree with this I don't think
it's the answer but whether it's the
answer or not is is it whether you agree
with it or not it's irrelevant it's
really interesting Mike talks about
um you know communication we we had
three years of Boris Johnson and people
said he was you know he blusted Boris
Johnson looks like the best prime
minister this country has ever had I I
am I am genuinely mightily shocked about
how incompetent this trust has come
across aren't you do you think you've
got Stockholm syndrome what does that
mean well do you think it's just been so
bad for so long that you think that
Boris Johnson looks better but I mean
look this has been terrible come on you
no hang on Boris Johnson's policies are
actually a lot closer to what Kia stalma
is putting out and what Liz truss has
given us but the problem with Liz truss
is that she's fired anyone with half a
brain out of the room there's no one
intelligent in there actually explaining
to them or they don't want to listen in
the case of the IMF which they're now
calling a lefty organization because
they're warning that the UK could fall
off a cliff Edge the only people who are
actually in control at the moment are
these Dreadful people called
um think tanks who work on tufton Street
places like the iea who are now addicted
I had them on last night
you're not that important they're not
listening I'm joking no they're not
they're not silly
they're writing the policy no this is
their wet dreams yeah but look where
it's going you know they're not only
writing the policy for very long if
that's their policies
the point is this that the problem here
is not the poor the problem here is not
the rich the problem is the people in
the middle because the people in the
middle are the people who won't be able
to afford their mortgage payments who
won't be able to put the heating on them
and then they're the ones and they're
the ones here's my point mate you talk
every day on the radio and you do it so
well you talk you know you talk to the
people that matter in this country the
exact people you're talking about yeah
who went this is a really good idea to
to tax we're going that we're going to
encourage the bankers and the and the
rich people to come back to London and
make money and it will trickle down
right now people don't think they can
pay their bills in October not in three
years time and I thought I said last
night I thought Liz trust would spend
two years buttering us up list trust
could be called Brave or she could be
called stupid people but they spent a
lot of money two days before the budget
on giving people money for their energy
bills right 150 billion they spent on
that a lot more than they spent on the
budget giveaway that's right no not
enough well it wasn't enough but the
point is nobody got upset about that the
markets
people did get upset about it
the markets didn't react let's put it
that way the point is the markets
reacted to a much smaller amount of
money on the Friday so what's going on
it's not the emote it's the it's the
credibility it's do they know what
they're doing and you could hear from
that uh those interviews that she did on
the BBC she doesn't even know how to
explain what she's doing but just let me
give you as an economist kind of rule of
thumb the cost of borrowing for order
three families for anything mortgage
loan credit card has gone up
from a quarter of a percent in January
to two and a quarter percent now and you
might think well that's not so much is
it it's nine times it's nine times so if
you say if a pint of beer is worth what
what is it a fiver let's say a piece
right if a pint was a fiber why are you
drinking yeah yeah if a pine was a fiber
it's the equivalent of a pint of beer
being 45 quid no and by the time it goes
to six percent it would be but it cannot
beer if beer is less important let's
talk let's talk about and you're quite
right about people if
the average person in this country
watching this reading the newspapers
turning on their radios and we're
sitting here arguing about whether she's
a good communicator
by anybody's standards I I'm not that
impressed you'll jump at me but you know
he is about as exciting as a tea bag
that's been squished out and put in the
bin in my humble opinion he's gonna walk
to power 33 points this just in by the
way you go Paul yes in the times 33 but
other polls tonight labor 21 and 17.
this is across the board he doesn't need
to open he's gone but that's the problem
is that he's not opening his mouth so
all of this is hedged on the fact that
Liz truss and the conservatives are not
a competent government he's actually not
put forward any policies that would
rectify the cost of living Scandal I
actually believe that's the only way the
labor party will be elected if they say
absolutely Jack between now but that's
that's not good enough because it's not
good if you actually get to the general
election you actually have to go out
fighting what are you going to tell
people you're like well we just won't be
as bad as them no we did say he did say
something and they've got a very clear
thing they would have kept our energy
bills the same as the conservatives so
that the average uh the average
household pays about two and a half
grams you're an economist Mike knows
that feel this I feel this really really
strongly when I was brought up it was
really simple there was a decom decom I
can't even say the word there was a line
between the Tories were supposed to be
fiscally responsible and they would you
know you didn't buy what you couldn't
afford the labor party would promise to
will give the miners this the Dockers
this the rep and then suddenly inflation
went to 30 and everybody was messed up
it seems that the whole thing's gone on
its head that the tourists have borrowed
money that we are all right
how much money that they've put how much
money that they've they've borrowed the
issue so what they've done with these
tax breaks they're hoping to make back
45 billion pounds over the next five
years through these tax cuts do you know
how much interest they're going to be
paying next year 100 billion 100 billion
that's over five years but here's the
thing as well either the the the
furlough business we should say that
borrowed more money during furlough
during the pandemic than almost the
entire history of government in this
country yeah until 2005 right 500
billion is borrowed right the thing
about the bank of England interest rates
I think Paul is that they were
profligate they should have known that
you couldn't keep artificially low
interest rates like that they were bound
to go up you know we're old enough to
remember the 70s and the 80s when people
had 15 mortgages of course you're not
you've just got bad memory the point is
that at the end of the day you know
people are going to find that they've
been buying things they can't afford you
know you walk around the Streets of
London people are driving very expensive
cars and they can't afford they're
living in houses with mortgages they
can't afford them to do that it doesn't
matter they're individuals
we are we are where we are and and
Johnson Builders into this tuna got us
into this Golden Brown attorney well I'm
a labor supporter I'd say Gordon Brown
and Tony Blair also played their part
but what we've got now is the government
and it's literally this it's got its
foot on the accelerator and it's got its
foot on the brake Bank of England trying
to slow things down yeah government's
trying to speed the economy up that
doesn't work what happens is they
eventually the engine Burns right we can
talk about this all night some other
stuff um this makes me sick to the
stomach uh Anna sakolis the American
lady Anna should say who came out of her
residence driving the wrong way and and
Harry done blessing was killed uh
tonight I believe or today has been told
that she must appear in court in England
that's not going to happen is it well I
don't imagine she wants to I mean I
don't understand why they were able to
have a hearing this morning or this
afternoon uh with her in absentia doing
it down a zoom link you know because
surely if you're going to be answering
charges you'd have to be in the court
don't you and there's no extradition
treaty between us and the Americans so
well I don't I don't think they'll go
for that I just don't think they will
diplomatically how would you feel if you
were a parent how would you feel if you
were Anne I don't I I don't believe that
she's doing this off her own back I
think she's being told not to appear or
not to what do you mean how would you
feel if you're around what about the
parents of the kid that was killed yeah
but we don't know the circumstances it
hasn't gone to trial then come to court
and explain the circumstances what if
she's not allowed to that's the thing
what if there are powers above her who
would not allow her to the U.S
why would it benefit the American
government to prevent a person who's
been accused of killing a kid to come
here and face Justice what if you were
under the official Secrets like she was
leaving an RAF military base wasn't she
that's the issue is that she physically
may not be allowed to come over here and
we're now victim blaming someone
if that was the case maybe she's under
duress maybe she's being told what to do
wow maybe she's guilty and needs to come
here and face Justice potentially but
what if she's not allowed to interesting
one um you might have heard this tonight
the Queen's death certificate was
released earlier old age yes my favorite
part is the fact that in uh occupation
it says the queen which I think is
brilliant of great occupation that isn't
it I mean there it is on the screen uh
you can see that I think that's what she
died of
died of old age at 10 past three
um everybody's now saying oh what about
you you know what why are they releasing
it are they releasing it but why do
people have to why don't you just accept
it they release it because it's a public
document in death certificates of public
documents I mean it was the queen I
wouldn't release it the it solves a a a
little mystery which is at what point
did they brought you know how long did
it take for her to die pass away her
family to certify that and then the
broadcasters got it because there's a
lot of maniac stuff about there she's
already dead yeah you know and I think
that um it kind of explains that what
the broadcasters were doing uh was
following their own rules and the
pre-planned and so there's no mysteries
about it I must say in the days since
the Majesty died the greatest Monarch
this country has ever had or will ever
have we have a government in turmoil and
the King who's apparently going to be
investigated for accepting cash that
never happened on her watch
um there's an article in the newspaper
today about how yoga this is the World
Health Organization honest to God this
does my head in uh they said that office
officers should offer yoga classes to
tackle spiraling rates of depression in
the workplace so I got I created in the
studio earlier a peers-free Zone and
this is my
[Music]
look how Zen they are where is that
madman Morgan he's on the golf course
look how calm and tranquil you should
have heard the squeals because they
tried to maintain those positions I've
got a small language yes can you imagine
can you imagine what about you Eva you
probably installed that onion I can't
imagine it you can't you like yoga I
love it that's why I'm so Zen are you
there I'm gonna do it after this program
the most
of my life
what's what's your favorite I never said
what's your favorite position can you
show us can you come on why not I can't
show you why not they want you to I've
got a risky dress and a mic pack that's
falling out yeah Michael show you could
you do it could you do anything I'm not
really no I don't do yoga I'm not
stressed I don't feel stressed I never
felt stressful
I did it a long time ago but I can't
remember any of the moves not really no
do you know what though
it's a good idea because we need to get
people back in the workplace there's a
labor shortage there's a shortage of
skills I think people should go back to
the office to work not do yoga classes
just to opinion I could be wrong do you
not think well you can't what's your
favorite position a downward dog
I don't quite know what to say thanks to
the um I don't even know what to say I'm
I'm speechless next tonight the downward
dog everyone wants a fair price for
Energy bills but is it right not to pay
them at all next we'll talk to the
campaigner who's encouraging all of us
not to pay our bills in a day of action
on Saturday and check this a new poll
says We're a nation of tired overweight
layer belts but how do we tackle bulging
Britain I'll talk to a weight loss coach
who says we need to be cruel to be kind
that's coming next don't go anywhere
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my friends now energy costs are set to
rise again this weekend leaving millions
of us facing a grim choice between
Heating and eating this winter pmli's
trust has been accused of repeatedly
misleading the public over Rising bills
by claiming that nobody nobody will pay
more than two and a half thousand pounds
a year the truth is though that not
everyone will see their yearly cost stay
below that so-called cap look at these
figures those of us in a detached house
will average pay 3 330 quid a year
people in the semi-detached house
they're looking at 2 650. now the two
and a half thousand pound price cap will
apply to other types of household yes
including flats and Bungalows now I
don't know if you've heard about this
group it's a campaign group called don't
pay UK and they are basically saying
don't pay your bill Saturday is a day of
coordinated protest and given the fact
that this is going to have a massive
fact on people's personal finances the
question tonight is is it irresponsible
now joining me to discuss this is
campaigner from don't pay UK Cameron
Joshy and personal finance expert Gemma
Godfrey there we go I got there again
good evening Pete's euros
oh come on
welcome camera and welcome let's start
with you can I just say the obvious
thing encouraging people not to pay
their bills is illegal and irresponsible
isn't it well actually not paying your
bills isn't illegal in this country and
if you don't pay your bills you won't be
disconnected so in 2018 only six people
in this country were disconnected not
paying their bills so it doesn't really
work like that anymore but doesn't it
push people further into debt
um no not paying I mean your bills could
could expand in the longer term well
surely if you don't pay a bill you're
charged interest on it aren't you yeah
but our hope well then you'll be further
in debt won't you exactly but I hope you
just said you wouldn't be in debt but
you've just admitted that you will be in
debt the whole point of our campaign is
that we're stronger together together we
are the strongest force for change in
this country if enough of us strike on
the October 1st and throughout the month
these bills but you're going to say that
to somebody watching that who is further
in debt because they take your advice on
Saturday and there's a debt collector at
the door explain that Cameron Joshi how
you expect people to believe that your
campaign is viable and right our
campaign is here to protect people who
are already on prepayment meters as we
speak we're here to stop this system
from installing more prepayment meters
and pushing more people into poverty if
we go on as we are currently going on
any prepayment stops paying their bills
we do not Advocate people on prepaid
meters are charged the higher tariff as
it is they shouldn't stop paying we
don't Advocate they do they still get
involved help me out I mean look there
are millions of families who are going
to face a really tough decision around
being able to keep their families warm
or be able to feed them and there are
millions of families that are not going
to be able to pay and then words
absolutely and there needs to be more
support there there needs to be more
that energy companies are doing what the
government's doing that the challenge
that we're facing here is that if
somebody you know doesn't pay there are
energy companies that the regulator said
to them they are under an obligation to
try and help people find a payment plan
so for example if you contact your
utility provider they are obligated to
review your payments potentially reduce
them potentially if you can get through
on the phone I suppose I mean that that
is the big challenge but if you can get
more time from them then they are giving
you the payment holiday to be able to
give you a reprieve they also have
hardship funds they're also grants and
schemes there are other things because
they're concerned but we're friends do
you agree with his approach I mean what
we're talking about is you're actually
asking for civil unrest do you agree
with that because that's what he's
asking what I do agree with is coming
together and I do agree that the more
that we can come together and campaign
because 2500 is not the cap you know
people especially the most vulnerable
are going to be spending I'm sure people
stop paying their bills but the concern
is is that what it does is it actually
plays into the energy companies hands
where they then have the ability to
switch people onto more expensive
tariffs switch them on to prepayment
meters can I just jump in here and say
that the whole point of this campaign is
that we are not here just to protest are
you say we're here talking about I'm
talking about 200 000 people who've
signed up already and I'm talking about
1.7 million people who are according to
polls going to cancel the direct debit
this month is quite easy from the cheap
seats to be this voice of the people
though because you're a career
campaigner aren't you come on I'm not a
career campaign you went to a posh
Westminster school where it was 30 grand
a year for legal fairness you were part
of Extinction Rebellion you were
arrested in April 2019 for obstructing
the highway you're now a climate Justice
organizer a direct action group global
Justice your career protester aren't you
you're one of those people from a rich
background who thinks it's easy to stand
up and tell people on Lower incomes what
they should do to be better off if you
actually genuinely been a position where
you cannot pay your bill I've got two
things to say to that first of all yes I
came exactly from that background I'm
not going to hide it secondly I
experienced extreme disability from the
age of 18. I know what it's like to
depend on the NHS for your life I know
what it's like to wake up after an
operation blinded by doctors who are
overworked I know how that is I know how
is to suffer and I can't pay my energy
bills this winter you can secondly how
big are your energy bills this winter my
energy bills are over twice what they
were before I'm on Universal Credit I
can't get a job you get the disability
benefit from applying for it but it
takes months the second thing I want to
say is that Jeremy I know that the
reason why people point this out is
because I'm everything that other people
from privilege who are running this
country hate I'm exactly what people
like that should have done whether
you've got a conscience but also they
should have turned around and realized
what they live off and turn and fight
for the people one of the things that
I'm absolutely and the reason I put that
to you was for this reason
um one of the things that I find
appalling whether it's the mortgage
situation we were talking about earlier
whether it's energy whether it's food is
there doesn't seem to be any planning
there doesn't seem to have been any
foresight we can get into that whole big
argument about should house
really yeah I think there is a plan the
whole plan is that the rich get richer
off of every crisis I bet you I bet I
bet you and your lot this week are
absolutely justified in what you're
saying because of what trust has done
and is exactly she's produced a plan
which gives the millionaires in the
society including yourself Jeremy 55 000
in tax breaks and ordinary people get
three so you're now assuming that you
know what I'm worth are you I know
you're worth five million dollars what's
that Wikipedia or something it's also
says they've been married twice they've
been married three times to get you
facts right let me ask you this in terms
of the people out there do you genuinely
bottom line believe that not paying
their bill I mean look you know this
it's true both of you the missed
payments could be marked as defaults on
your credit report they also could pass
the debt on to debt collection agencies
through this I can completely accept
this we don't want to do this right the
alternative is that this will happen
anyway to vulnerable people the more
people that join this campaign we
produce a ring around the most
vulnerable society if enough of people
join none of this will happen to anyone
they'll have to stop do you think and
one of the things that that we pride
ourselves on as a nation and I and I
tell you what respect to you right
because you've come here and you're put
in your case and I genuinely mean that
one of the things that this nation is
proud of is free speech and the ability
to protest do you genuinely hand on
Hearts think this will make a difference
yes you know why because over a million
people are already doing this and polls
show that they're inspired by our
campaign if over a million people do
this the energy companies will be out
three billion pounds would you
understand from my point of view we have
to responsibly broadcast and we can't
say to people you get this oh I know you
do don't pay your bills because what am
I supposed to do when they then ring and
go I've got a debt collection agency at
my door what would your advice what
would your group's advice be at that
point because that can happen our whole
point is that there is no other option
for many other people and we're going to
step in all of us to be stronger
together if enough of us do this the
courts will be jammed up they will not
be able to put you on a pre-pamp meter
they don't have a million people are
there other options
the only thing that I'm really concerned
about is just is that if you are able to
reach your utility provider and get a
and get a reprieve and get a holiday on
your Energy payments without arrears
fees debt moving you know the threat of
moving on to a prepayment meter that
could be an option for some people that
are in a really really tough situation
what you're basically saying isn't and I
said this the other night to be fair
you're going to go God we've got Common
Ground presumably any business survives
only on the its customers buying paying
and settling the debt from from having
what they have you're saying that if
enough people say to these energy
companies you've had it too good for too
long we ain't paying they are going to
have to look at themselves and shame
that's not what we're saying what are
you saying then we're saying that the
government will be forced to step in to
bring energy bills down to a level we
can pay our campaign has already made
Liz truss Force energy bills down to 2
500 pounds it has already worked but
don't get me wrong I think it's
appalling what I'm worried about is and
and you can learn
you can sit there and go Jess that's not
fair because I don't want to be one of
those people who says it's so take okay
to complain and not come up with an
answer I'm just worried about the
implications if p people in their minds
are encouraged to blame them I
completely agree with that so can I just
say that our campaigns locally people I
encourage people to sign up and join a
local group because we will be there for
people in hardship we're making plans to
produce warm Banks instead of food banks
places where people can come to be warm
we're producing plans to stand in the
way of bailiffs if they try and get
money from you on your door I've done it
before people been kicked out of their
homes disabled people who'll be on the
streets who would die that way it's
completely legal to do bailiffs are not
allowed to use Force down to your hope
and I want to say one other thing sure
one thing I am really scared of is that
this crisis like every other crisis is
made in a way that the ordinary people
pay and the rich people are scot-free
with 120 billion pounds don't take me
wrong fair play to you for coming here
and arguing it because here's what I
would say we have to responsibly
broadcast and not say completely right
you understand that but maybe you're
right maybe it is time for people to say
is enough is enough and have to go to a
break but Liz trusses you quite rightly
say as as this week said if you're rich
you don't have to pay tax and if you
poor you do thank you really good to
meet you Cameron Joshy uh Gemma Godfrey
coming up next mad Vlad is about to
formally Annex four more parts of
Ukraine uh we have a man on Nexus
there's perhaps we should bomb Russia
it's the only way to stop the war and a
poll has painted a place pretty
unflattering picture of bulging Britain
tired fatter and less fit than any other
country but the answer to the doctors is
do they need to be given some home
truths we'll do that soon I'm talk we're
back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
uh welcome back to uncensored before we
get on to Russia hello to my mate Davis
it's with sat here glued really great
stuff love the pace and energy and we
can't wait for you to get after the um
uh the people who eat too much uh we'll
do that right welcome back Russia will
formerly Annex as much as 18 of Ukraine
this weekend sham referenda held at
gunpoint have produced results that
would make Kim Jong-un blush I've got
that wrong junk anyway there you go now
there's fears that Putin will use this
fake legitimacy to claim Russia itself
is under direct attack
but Russian forces are definitely on the
ropes thousands are fleeing conscription
elderly reserves are bound for the front
line so could threatening a real direct
attack on Russia at its moment of
weakness actually be the fastest way to
end this unbelievably cruel War joining
me now is President Putin's former
advisor Sergey Markov who last time he's
on the show just basically did no no no
no it appears so he can wait a Ukrainian
MP aletsky gonchirenko down the line and
with me in the studio journalist and
Economist Paul Mason we met you earlier
Paul um I am not for War I I find what
this man has done in a Sovereign Nation
disgusting but when you consider that he
is going to Annex territory that isn't
his he shall referenda thou at best
illegal and and fundamentally flawed and
when you see there was a picture from
space where you could see Russians
fleeing the country do you not think
rather than talk about is it time to
attack him do we have any confidence
that the Russian people might wise up
and go let's get rid of this madman even
if they wanted to that it would mean
risking life and limb against a very
very serious Security State what I'm
saying today is that the reason he's
seizing these four these four
territories is he's losing the war yeah
he's giving himself his own rules state
that if Russian territory is attacked or
the state is on the existential threat
he can use a nuclear weapon I think he
will a lot of the experts I speak to say
it's a non-negligible challenge it's a
risk and what has been going on this
week is that President Biden both
publicly and privately has been saying
if you do it you will face catastrophic
consequences now what I'm saying is that
we the people who the vultures of
America Britain France the three nuclear
democracies need to be thinking about
this before it happens the only way to
deter Putin for real is to present him
with a credible message that something
bad will happen to him I don't want to
talk about I'm sorry I have to say
strangely I'm with you to a degree
because I you know people have said
logistic we can't put troops on the
ground logistically you know we can help
we can provide you know we can provide
ammunition military help etc etc in
terms of logistical help but the truth
of the matter is still this man does
what he does it's going so wrong I want
to bring in aletsky gone shirenko a
Ukrainian Empire let's give you spoken
many times welcome to the show I love of
your description Russia is a dinosaur
with a very big body tiny hands and very
few brains
um the truth of the matter is is that
Russia and Putin are losing this War
aren't they that's the truth
absolutely and that's why Putin is like
a gesture of desperation he's making
this so-called referenda and tomorrow
this stage performance to show Russian
people and to the world some kind of
political success and to trying to cover
with this his complete military failure
but what I want to tell you is that now
is the exactly right moment to finish
with Putin's regime because uh in if in
the end of March Ukraine would have a
Weaponry that we have today we would
finish everything in the spring but
unfortunately we hadn't with what to
purchase Russians when after failed
Blitzkrieg they were retreating from
Kiev and from the northern part of our
country now is again the moment before
these hundreds of thousands mobilized
people will be sent to Ukraine to die
there because yes that is the problem
they just want to increase the body of
these dinosaurs that's not their problem
their problem is they're tiny head and
very small brain in it but even before
they will be sent and this Bloodshed
will happen we can want to I think
military defeats for Putin's regime and
it would not survive but for this we
need more Weaponry today for Ukraine
first of all let me bring in and armor
thank you let me bring in Sergey Markov
um Russia is a dinosaur
um with small bits and small brains um
the West according to you doesn't
respect Russian democracy but then you
respect Ukrainian democracy do you sir
but we cannot respect uh Ukrainian
democracy because Ukrainian democracy
death in 2014 when a junta took power in
Native after the military or strong or
the last democratically elected
president
we cannot respect Ukrainian democracy
because in such a regime such a fascists
like Alexia
I was into I was in cave this I was in
Kiev until 36 hours before this war
started and I met people from all
countries
trade unions human rights Left Right
Center Connecticut
what's going on was I imaginative was I
imagining that
uh I said I understand you interrupt me
because you played my arguments oh I'm
so sorry uh but it's very strange is
that you don't see the key that uh more
than uh uh sorti uh political parties in
Ukraine have been prohibited and the
main leader the main opposition party
has been arrested and under the torture
uh
with respect and I'll turn your
microphone off just out on a second with
respect when I when I when I sit and
listen to a Russian trying to educate us
about fairness and democracy it's
laughable but let's move on from there
let's let's get you to ask the answer
the obvious question
your leader who is withdrawn to his
Palace somewhere wherever it is right is
conscripting elderly people thousands
hundreds of thousands of people are
fleeing his regime trying to get the
hell out of your country because he has
led your country into a war it cannot
win it won't win and it damn well
shouldn't win and I don't know how you
have the the audacity to sit here and be
happy that Dad's Army is being sent in
because the world will not accept this
Sergo it will not accept it and so it
shouldn't come on man be honest
don't repeat same mistakes which
Napoleon Bonaparte and uh already made
about Russian army and when they spoke
that Russian army is too big do not
repeat their mistake either way you will
have same result as they it's a military
disaster for Russia isn't it it's a
military yeah I don't say no man I'm not
having that come on at the Ukrainian
it's already happened pushing back
aren't they it's not a disaster
we can understand Sergey because Sergey
can't speak in Russia and finally he has
a place where he can speak on British TV
so that's why he's trying just to use
this opportunity but uh first of all he
called me fascist you know I know more
poems of Russian poets than putting all
his into Russian including Sergey Markov
altogether so it's complete nonsense and
today in Ukraine russian-speaking people
with weapons in their hands are
defending the country from Putin and
from russian-speaking people from Russia
that is the reality speaking about
military disaster that Russia received
in Ukraine they were saying in February
that they would take care of in four
days and their satellite lukashenka with
their goal later of Belarus he said that
in several weeks there will be near La
manche but you see that they can't go
through Dunbar us for all seven months
so for sure after all these myths about
second largest and strongest army in the
world they completely failed um say that
sorry sir again we've got a problem with
your microphone Paul and I think in many
ways what we've seen there is rehearsed
the old arguments between Ukraine but
there is a new argument if Putin uses or
is incredibly threatening to use a
nuclear weapon that makes it our problem
because it's not just a threat to us
every small country every third world
country I think we have to be very
careful not to sit by and allow this man
to do the ultimate but of course then
the Saudis will want will want nukes at
Taiwan will want nukes and we'll be in a
world of pain we have to stop that all
right nice and fair Sergey uh your your
the last word from you do you do you not
believe the truth that the Russian army
is in turmoil the conscripts of fleeing
and Russia faces the most humiliating
defeat because it has a leader who
thinks he can go into a Sovereign Nation
and jump around it's not going to work
May it will never ever work
you just told the trash is going to take
80 percent of Ukrainian territory inside
Russia and same time Russia is defeating
it's something in contradiction in your
mind probably and Russia free country
that why in Russia you can leave country
and you can have okay whatever
projects
I mean Ukraine all borders is close and
finally oh God not used nuclear weapons
against not nuclear Ukraine thank you
very much indeed enough is enough can I
just say one thing Paul thank you very
much thank you Sergey can I just say one
thing when you listen to that dire tribe
you understand why sadly the Russian
people who have no real information
given to them by their government who
are basically conditioned into how they
think you understand why people like
Sergey Markov talk like they do wouldn't
it be interesting if the Russian people
were told the truth right next tonight
Brits exercise less we eat less fruit we
sleep less than people in other
countries is it time to do something
about our obesity problem we'll debate
on accident I'll come right back in
three don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the final part of
uncensored for Thursday night right good
news a new multinational survey bear
pollster yougov says that Britain is
World leading sadly it's being tired
overweight slobs 71 percent of Brits
failed to do sport at least twice a week
twice compared to a global average of 57
more than half of us don't eat fruit at
least once a day and Brits are also
fatter than other nationalities one
third of the UK residents describe
themselves as obese and overweight
joining me now is um weight loss coach
and renowned no-nonsense fat fighter
Steve Miller and of course my wonderful
journals you're right what let's start
with Steve
um how are you Steve what's happened to
your band
oh my God I'll tell you what I wish I
had got a band mind you I I actually
nearly made something called Steve
Miller's uh gastric bands I reckon I'd
have made a mince if I'd have done that
so you're a weight loss coach who
Advocates the truth so when somebody
comes to you obese and says listen
what
yes I'm a Gob listen I'm a Gob on a
stick now let's let's we're talking
about fat here right now the real world
is from my experience is this is that we
have a lot of people that do take
responsibility and they do take action
and they do do what they should do but
unfortunately we have a whopping
proportion of the UK people waiting that
unfortunately do unfortunately do
struggle with what I call can't be
bothered itis but I'll tell you why
Jessa we're getting like this we're
getting fatter it's because we're
normalizing it it's like we all should
sit round now and sing if you're happy
and you're fat clap your hands you know
and and you know even saying the word
fat these days you get trolled on on on
Twitter I mean it's like my TV show I
mean they go crazy when they see the
YouTube clips um thank you very much
today looks like Alan cards
um have you got can't be bothered no
absolutely not no I I have got though is
I'm not saying you're fat I what I do
have is an extreme kind of um opposition
to anyone who wants to tell me what to
do yeah so if somebody starts telling me
to do something I'll immediately do the
complete opposite thing and I think the
trouble with this country that we now
live in is there's loads of people like
Steve who want to tell everybody else
how to behave I think you should go back
into his house shut the door and not
come out again
Ava Ava
I can't be like Hey listen here I've got
something to say to Mike Graham Mike
Graham you're too gorgeous to be fat I
honestly one of them
speak to me woman come on no I I think
that we're oversimplifying this I think
that you know it's totally unfair to say
that British people are just lazy I
think that we're time impoverished I
think that people genuinely don't have
time to cook meals anymore because we're
both work both members of the household
are working nine to five jobs and it's a
lot easier to put processed food on the
table than it is to put healthy food and
a lot more a lot cheaper it's extremely
expensive to eat healthy it's really not
actually you can be very very healthy I
cook an awful lot right and you can eat
very healthily for very little money you
can make vegetable soup for literally no
money I know this is something that has
been a rail going on in in some quarters
for a while but it's wrong to say that
processed food is cheaper because it
isn't people guess it is it is we're
going down that argument where it's like
I'll just eat porridge I'll just eat a
baked potato with beef internet if you
actually wanted to make a vegetable soup
from scratch Not only would it cost you
a lot in time it would cost you probably
about 10 quid to make it yes it would
well what are you putting in it potato
and water no potatoes carrots celery a
bit of garlic you can put some lentils
in it
you know he's having a gin can you
cheeky sod go on wow what advice would
you give to Mike my friend to be very
careful come on
well well listen the first thing on a
serious note is that actually if you
look deeply it is cheaper to eat well
the problem is you've got to get out
there and find it it can be cheaper
right uh the advice to Mike Graham would
be do not do a diet and the British
people this is a great message for the
British people
if you could hurry up
laughs
all right right 80 20. eat eat healthily
80 of the time Mike and 20 a bit of what
you fancy because it's very helpful
you want to see you want to see the
stuff I cook I eat very healthily I
don't eat very much fat the problem for
me is that I drink quite a lot and
that's more yeah that's why I look like
this it's going to do with the food I
eat I don't eat that much are you really
a weight loss coach
can you no you know what it's not Joe
Wicks hear me
listen no I'm not do you know what
you're absolutely right I am the most on
I'm probably I don't look like one do I
I know I don't but I tell you what for
some reason I'm really good at it and
you know what at the heart of it is it's
about we're very shallow when we talk
about weight loss we always think about
food and drink actually it's a mindset
yeah
um listen it's been an absolute pleasure
I I'm slightly I'm I'm in awe I'm gonna
throw away this shirt because we've got
the same one on but thanks very much
indeed good luck with your weight loss
coaching Steve Miller who lost his band
turned into Alan Carr and then told Mike
Graham to eat vegetable soup got this
show gets more weird every night Ava
thank you go away I'm joking do you do
you not think there is a slight truth in
that certain people are lazy no I don't
I really I think that's unfair I think
it's so unfair it's like the Dominic
Robb book do you remember that Dreadful
book that the government Minister who's
now long gone brought out and said that
British workers were the most idle in
the world it's so on Fair we just live a
different lifestyle I'm with Mike it's
about Choice okay you make the choice
you stand by your choice if you want to
do this or that or the other take
responsibility and face up too can I
also all these people that say exercise
right there's more people in a e because
of exercise than there is because
they've eaten too much
well listen you two can carry on arguing
but I've got to say that that is the end
I might have to point out the Piers
Morgan uh went to play golf in the
Dunhill links for the last two days and
sadly at this moment in time is in last
position out of 168 call but no I guess
not he'll be back on Monday uh Mike
Graham 10 o'clock tomorrow morning on
talk radio we're on the breakfast show
at 6 30. they're going out but don't eat
any Burgers we won't be eating munch on
a carrot good luck with a double dog
that's it from me whatever you are Make
It Uncensored have a great night see you
soon Tara
foreign
[Music]
what was my biggest career moment after
spending about 25 years of Fleet Street
there's loads of stories I could tell
you but actually I think I did an
overnight show for Tool radio in the
early days the night of the brexit
referendum and that was actually quite a
milestone because of course we started
off thinking that remain had won and at
half cost two quarter three after Nigel
farage had already said he'd lost it
turned out he hadn't lost but it turned
out we were leaving the European Union
so that was quite a shocking
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Zora Silverman The
Fallout from the turmoil course to UK
markets has continued as a yougov poll
for the time shows secure stama's labor
party 33 points ahead of the Tories it's
thought to be the largest lead for the
party in a quarter of a century it's as
Liz truss has call for patience and
unity over the plans and despite a group
of MPS urging the chancellor to bring
forward his economic forecast
quasi-courteng says the government will
stick to its growth plans and U.S
President Joe Biden says early reports
in Florida suggest hurricane Ian has led
to a substantial loss of life after the
category 4 storm caused severe flooding
which has seen people trapped in their
homes and millions left without power
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]